all right y'all I have a great story
from social media I want to share before
we finish the hour this is what I'm
liking so as kids Gabriella and her
cousins would get together for
sleepovers at their grandparents um who
they call Nona and Nono they had to eat
and dance play games watch movies it's a
good time uh now these cousins are all
grown up and last month they decided to
revive the tradition but they didn't
tell Nona or no no they just showed up
with bags and blankets in hand check
this out
[Music]
SLE are you happy we're sleeping
over don't right I'm sleeping with you
guys oh
my that's a cute video and it already
has 10 million hits online let's catch
up with this family all watching on NBC
New York what's up y'all
hi oh my gosh well I mean okay I'm going
to start with no no no no like what did
you think when they all showed up were
you like wait what could believe it I
couldn't believe it all of a sudden they
come in wish sleep NOA wh sleeping NOA
singing the Italian music a I love it so
much that's a lot of estrogen no no I'm
just saying you're hanging out with a
lot of
estrogen so Gabriel I got to start with
you how how did the idea come up like
how was the night how did it end so
basically my cousin Christina was at my
Nona's house and on Monday and all my
Nona kept saying was I wish you would
just sleep over I wish you would just
sleep over so then we were like we knew
we were going to go visit CU we just got
back from college so we were like all
right let's go do something let's
actually go sleepover because they'll be
so surprised we ended up you know we
playing the favorite music we brought
chicken parm and eggplant to go eat we
baked cookies we played ches we played
card games it was like the best night I
love this so much it's so
cool you have such a beautiful family
and I love man people like I hope
they're inspired by this we should do
this more often I always have dance
parties with my kids but they're still
seven and nine so I hope we're still
doing it when they're in their 20s and
30s but all right thank you guys so much
for sharing this video it's such a
beautiful family video and a beautiful
experience we should all have with our
families good luck no no with all those
women all right I'm liking your post
right now and that's not all y'all our
season long partner pilot pin makers
have precise the go-to pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to H honor truly
Unstoppable families just like yours so
they're going to be riding you a check
for $1,000 you can use it for your next
[Applause]
sleepover divy that up however you
will thank you guys so much thank you to
all our guests this hour common ala
Ashley Rob jaon Mor you have a great day
if it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
changing thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home